[MUSIC]
So I'm 20 years old, and like every
other girl, I love going to school.
But I also like missing school one day or
two.
I remember the first day I received
a notification from my teacher
saying that we wouldn't
have classes the next day.
And then the next day I
received another notification
with one more day without classes.
But then one day became one week, and
one week became one month, and
one month a couple of months.
And then the entire school
year had to be readjusted for
the amount of classes we were missing.
Don't think I was on vacation
mode during that time, no.
I would be walking down the streets
with a little pot my mom gave me and
that I would use as a drum,
to go perfectly well with my chantings.
[FOREIGN] Which means, not one step back.
This was 2002 in Caracas,
Venezuela, in the first oil strike
opposition leaders organized to
protests against the government.
This picture was taken a couple of weeks
ago, people still protesting in the same
street against the same government
17 years after that strike.
If you happen to read the news,
you've probably seen Venezuela in
the headlines over the past months.
Words like hyperinflation, crisis, unrest,
are fairly common, but what I see in
this picture is larger than that.
I see the hands of people I know, like
my mom and my dad that still live there.
And more recently, I see hope,
hope of some day being able to
come back to what I call home.
With this talk I want you to understand
what is going on in Venezuela now, but
I also want to show you
the nation behind the news.
I want to you that despite the crisis,
there is a strong social
fabric being built in Venezuela
that is worth standing for.
But to do that let's travel
back in history for a bit.
Recognize this face?
This is Hugo Chavez,
he was elected as president of Venezuela
in 1999 with a populous proposal
that came to change the traditional
politics of what was one of
the wealthiest countries in Latin America.
He would stay in power for
14 years, until he died.
During that time the price of an oil
barrel multiplied by ten, and
considering that we sit on top of
the largest oil reserves in the world,
you would expect Venezuela to become
an even richer country, but no.
Instead, the government
increase our foreign debt,
destroyed our internal production
capacity, and fueled an overwhelming
amount of corruption that
left the country in mystery.
By 2013, the year Chavez died, I was
graduating from the University, and I had
spent my five years in college fighting
against the government, all unsuccessful.
New elections were scheduled and
Nicholas Maduro,
announced by the government's propaganda
as Chavez's son, was elected president.
He would stay in power for six more years.
Terrified, I left the country
as part of one of the large
migration waves that fled Venezuela.
Since then oil price plummeted, and years
of mismanagement, wrong public policies,
and no investment in infrastructure
whatsoever, came to surface.
Venezuela progressed towards one of the
worst socioeconomic crisis of our times.
Please look at this graph, we are compared
to Syria, without actually being at war.
Our annual inflation rate is estimated
in somewhere between 1.6 million and
10 million percent, can you imagine that?
90% of our population lives
under the poverty line,
children have to scavenge for
food in the streets, and
babies are dying in hospitals because
antibiotics are nowhere to be found.
So what is happening now?
By the beginning of this year,
Maduro announced he would
continue with his presidency and
he has the support of a few countries,
like Russia, Cuba, and China.
But this time, after years of
fighting against a government,
we are fighting for a government.
Juan Guaidó is the President
of the National Assembly.
And he announced by the beginning of
this year that he would stepping in as
interim president.
I have to explain a bit better
what all of these means.
Years ago we elected
a National Assembly we all voted for,
and Maduro last year
decided to strip away the power of this
National Assembly and created a new one.
It is as if President Trump decided
to create a new Congress or
Republicans because the one
in power is fully Democrat.
And even worse,
this National Assembly called for
presidential elections that were a fraud,
and that's where Maduro won.
So Juan Guaidó, the President of
the National Assembly we had elected,
is following articles
in our constitution and
he's legitimately
announced his presidency.
Immediately, millions of Venezuelans
started supporting him, and
that's the picture I showed
in the beginning of the talk.
Not only Venezuelans, we have the support
of the international community.
Over 60 countries have already
legitimized his presidency,
including the US, the European Union,
and our neighbors, Colombia and Brazil.
Now, don't get me wrong,
there's still a lot of uncertainties,
and I don't really know what will happen.
But maybe, just maybe, this time we do
change things and a new government starts.
For the first time in my life I felt
that coming back is a possibility.
That the notion of rebuilding my
country is actually not that far.
And that is an amazing feeling to have.
I need you to understand something
about countries in crisis,
there is never just one side to a story.
That little girl that wandered the streets
in Caracas did not grow up in this
reality.
The country I love is much
more than these stats.
This is where my family lives, this is
where I learned how to ride a bike,
this is where I did
the most mundane things,
like watching The Notebook with my best
friend and crying silently over that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] And I can tell you something,
I am not alone.
I can probably say that there a millions
of Venezuelan that love their country and
that fighting now for a better future.
Despite the daily struggles,
regular civilians, like you and
me, are solving for
the inefficiencies of a failed state.
We are threading a social
fabric filled by creativity,
innovation, and above all, resilience.
As an example, if you hop in a bus in
Caracas today you might catch the bus TV,
this is an initiative created by a group
of young journalists that worried
about the censorship of our national TV,
decided to ignite change themselves.
And in a very simple, yet effective way,
they showcase the news to
the lowest classes in Caracas.
Like them,
we have medical students that created
first aid groups to support
in the violent protests.
And we have hundreds of nonprofits that
are increasing their mission to cover for
basic needs.
There's for example, the one I work with.
That is originally focused in
sustainable tourism, but is now
reinvented itself to also provide energy
to communities that desperately need it.
This is what we, Venezuelans,
are doing, but what can you do?
Well, moving forward we'll require
a lot of help from abroad.
And there are couple of ways
you could be part of it.
First, through humanitarian aid and
donations.
Second, through votes in favor of
certain decisions in your own countries.
And three, by leaving this room and
sharing this message.
Help me raise awareness.
I hope that the next time that
you read new about Venezuela or
any other country in crisis you're curious
enough to go beyond their surface and
look for the rebuilders.
I can guarantee,
you'll be positively surprised, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]